[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: Welcome to the
Google Cloud Marketplace
Private Catalog.
The Private Catalog is a service
on Google Cloud allowing Cloud
admins to control
distribution of solutions
to ensure compliance
and governance,
and make solutions
easily discoverable
within their organization.
So what does that really mean?
An admin at a company
wants to ensure
that the platform's
group has access
to a set of Cloud solutions.
Some solutions are
custom to the company,
and others are solutions they've
purchased on Google Cloud.
And they need to be
curated by region, by team,
and different criteria
your organization needs.
The way they do this is
creating a catalog instance,
add solutions to it, and share
it with a group of users.
Not only is it shared,
Private Catalog
can ensure that the solution is
configured and ready to deploy
or use all in one place.
Cloud admins can manage a
central place for end users
to find approved solutions.
Admins have the ability to
push solutions with the latest
patches or versions.
End users don't have to worry
about what's being deployed,
and can be assured
that they're always
using the latest
and greatest version
of every approved solution.
Admins can use templates to
add parameters for users.
They can place limits on
who can deploy resources,
and which resources
they can deploy.
And finally, we've
made it easy for admins
to take third-party solutions
from Google Cloud Marketplace
and add them to their
private catalog.
We're going to explore
the Admin view first,
which right now, is
in the zero state
with no catalogs or solutions.
We can get started
on changing that
by clicking Go to
Catalog Manager or Manage
Solutions on the left
side navigation bar.
Let's go ahead and
create a new solution.
Start by clicking solutions
in the left navigation bar,
and then create solution.
The Private Catalog supports
three solution types,
Terraform configs, Links,
and Deployment Manager.
Terraform is a tool
for building, changing
and versioning Cloud
Infrastructure safely
and efficiently.
Terraform configs are a way to
deploy first-party Google Cloud
Services, but using Terraform.
Links solutions are
really just a URL.
This could be to
documentation or whatever it
is that you need to point to.
Links work for SAS
solutions, such as a pointer
to MongoDB's product offering
on Google Cloud marketplace.
Deployment Manager
solutions are used
to deploy any Google Cloud
first-party service, including
storage, VMs,
containers or BigQuery.
For this example, we'll
select Terraform config.
A form will appear on the
right side of the screen.
The top six fields are
consistent across all solution
types, starting with
name and description,
and also including a
tagline for the Browse page
of the Private Catalog, an icon,
support information, and a link
to any relevant documentation.
[CLICKING]
After that, we need to add a
link to the Terraform config.
This one is called
Google Cloud Storage,
and it points to a zip
file in a GCS bucket,
gs://terraform
samples/gcs bucket.zip.
The zip file should include
your Terraform configs.
Once we've attached the
zip file, hit Create.
And this adds the solution to
the Private Catalog, a process
that takes a couple seconds.
If you're wondering what's
happening in the back end,
the system is leveraging Cloud
Build to run Terraform validate
and parse out the input
definitions for the product.
While that's
happening, the solution
will appear in
the table, and you
can click on it to review
the information that
was added earlier.
Validation status
will remain as pending
while the solution is being
processed, after which,
it should change to valid.
Let's add a send grade
email API link solution.
Again, click solutions
in the left navigation
bar, followed by create solution
in the bar above the table.
[CLICKING]
You can also add the
Deployment Manager solution.
Click Create Solution in
the bar above the table.
Enter basic metadata
for the solution.
[CLICKING]
And attach a zip file
for the solution.
This WordPress Deployment
Manager template
was downloaded from the
WordPress solution page,
available in the Marketplace.
Now let's create a catalog.
First, head to catalogs using
the left navigation bar.
A catalog is really just
a grouping of products.
And the way to make your
products available to end users
is by creating a catalog,
adding solutions to it,
and then sharing that
catalog with a part
of your organization's
Google Cloud hierarchy.
When creating catalogs, you
may want to group solutions
by region, by disciplines,
like development or testing,
or really whatever makes
sense for your company.
You can create as many
catalogs as you need.
Hit the Create catalog button.
The form prompts us to add a
catalog ID and a description.
This catalog is called DevTools,
with the descriptor development
tools.
Click Create to finish
setting up the catalog.
The new catalog appears
in the catalogs table.
Now that we've
created a catalog,
we can assign it a solution.
Click into the catalog
we've just created.
In the Details page,
click on Assign Solutions.
Find the Google Cloud
Storage solution
we created earlier
and press assign.
Let's go back to the catalogs
page using the Back button
at the top, and add
one more catalog
so we can see how
they work together.
We can name this one Test Tools
with the descriptor testing
tools.
Once the testing
catalog is saved,
we can assign the
link solution to it.
Now that we have two catalogs,
each containing solutions,
it's time to share them with the
right users in the Google Cloud
hierarchy.
Head back to catalogs
page and select
the two catalogs we've created.
Go to Share from the
options at the top.
And from here, you can
choose to share the catalog
at the organization
folder or project level.
We're going to share both
Catalogs at the project level
with a project called
Product Manager.
Everyone in the
Google Cloud hierarchy
with access to that
project will now
see and have access to the
solutions within the catalog.
We are now going to click
Browse Catalog on the top right
side of the screen to take
a look at the end user view.
Let's go ahead and filter by
the catalog we created earlier,
DevTools.
This brings up our Terraform
config, Google Cloud Storage.
Clicking on the solution
loads the Details page,
a page that is similar across
all three types of solutions
in the Private Catalog.
This makes it easy for
end users to quickly find
solutions they can use.
Now let's deploy our
Terraform config.
Click Deploy to begin
the new deployment.
Here we will fill out
the input variables
needed for the deployment.
For Terraform configs,
we also have something
like a pre-flight check.
When we click
Preview and Deploy,
the system will start
to run Terraform plan
in the background.
This happens without having
to install Terraform, get
the binaries or anything else.
These services are abstracted
from you and the end user,
allowing you to easily deploy
the solutions you need.
In this case, Terraform
plan has run successfully.
So we can go ahead and
deploy the solution.
In this case, we will
create a GCS bucket.
Once the deployment has
successfully completed,
the icon turns green.
This usually takes
a few minutes,
but it does depend on the
solution you are deploying.
Let's take a look
at a situation where
the deployment has failed.
Clicking the deployment
shows the logs,
enabling the user to potentially
self-service and fix the issue.
With our solution
successfully deployed,
we can go back to the
Private Catalog homepage
and browse all Terraform
deployments using the tab
in the left navigation bar.
The Private Catalog gives
organizations a single place
to discover approved solutions
that they can deploy,
knowing the solutions have
been approved and verified
by their Cloud admin.
It also looks a lot like the
Google Cloud marketplace,
and for a reason.
We've aimed to create
a consistent UI
experience to help you
and your users easily
navigate and enjoy the benefits
of the Private Catalog.
Ready to get going?
Begin building on Google Cloud
with $300 in free credits
and 20-plus always
free products.
Get started today.